triangle the sides are in the ratio of X
X square root of 3 + 2 X the X side is a
diagonally across from the 30-degree
angle 30 degree angle is a small angle
so the side across from that smallest
angle in this triangle will be the
shortest side if you go across from the
60-degree angle that's the medium length
side X square root of 3 and across from
the right angle that's the largest angle
so 2x is going to be the longest side so
just for your reference square root of 3
is about 1.7 okay approximately so this
is like X x times 1.7 and if you double
the shortest leg you're gonna get the
hypotenuse so you want to memorize these
ratios so you're gonna use these
triangles a lot as you go on but what
you can think of I'll just give you just
a brief overview how to do this if they
give you this side you double it to get
the hypotenuse okay and then you
multiply by square root of 3 to get the
longer leg if they give you the
hypotenuse you divide by 2 to get back
to the shorter leg and then multiply by
the square root of 3 to get the longer
leg the toughest one often is when they
give you this longer leg you have to
divide by the square root of 3 to get
back to the shorter leg which means you
might have to rationalize because you
don't want the square root in the
denominator and then you double it to
get the hypotenuse let's look at some
examples and we'll go through it so this
first one they're giving us the shortest
leg you see how it's across in the
30-degree angle all we have to do is
double it to get the hypotenuse 8 and
multiply by the square root of 3 we get
4 square root of 3 easy this one here a
little bit more challenging they give us
the hypotenuse C across from the right
angle that's the longest side that's the
2x side if we divide by 2 we get 5 for
the shorter leg now if we multiply by
the square root of 3 we get 5 root 3 for
the longer leg okay this one down here
they're giving us the longer leg okay
see the extra this extra 3 side 6 square
root of 3 so we're going to divide by
the square root of 3 to get back to the
shorter leg so 6 root 3 divided by
square root of 3 is just going to be 6
and if we double that because 2 times X
gives us the 2x side that's going to be
12
okay over here they give us the longer
leg so let's say this is the 30-degree
angle longer leg to get back to the
shorter leg we have to divide by the
square root of three here's where we
have to do a little bit of work okay we
don't want the radical on the bottom so
we're gonna rationalize that gives us
nine square root of three over three the
9 and the three reduced so that's going
to reduce down to three square root of
three if we double it now we get the
hypotenuse which is six square root of
three and we've got it okay last one
they give us the shorter leg okay you
can see that's across from the 30-degree
angle and then you double it to get the
hypotenuse so that's six square root of
two and then here if you multiply by the
square root of three that's going to
give you three square root of six three
square root of six okay so this is how
to work with the 30-60-90 special right
triangle check out my video learning how
to work with the 45-45-90 special right
triangle and I'll see you in the next
video